bringing the white rook across but now
after a check viking steps back and this
check finally does win the hopeless the
helpless white rook
and hopeless yeah i agree
okay we see the white rook go up but now
the other pawns and central pawns drop
from white yeah not only does the pawn
drop but you still cannot push your
a-pawn
i mean
it's yeah it's gone
it's the same kind of technique as they
say wow yeah and not very
challenging technique yeah
yeah yeah here comes the move from
magnus and what will john do okay he
didn't
and he finishes it
wow magnus carlsen he wins game 11. he
defends his title the norwegian winning
his fifth world championship match let's
hear what the players are saying
what a moment
in the hill
if i just click on d4 it should be
closer
because 695 could be slightly i don't
know it will be fine then i mean
no but then repeat five at some point so
this time
structure yeah
has taken his chances he has thrown
endurance
and has been unbeatable ryana pomnyacci
after 11 games in dubai you guys it's
over magnus carlsen he keeps his crown
let's go down to dubai